how's it going reject nation I'm Greg
Alba I'm John old Humphrey hopefully
this gets up on YouTube let's find out
we're gonna watch from a new topper war
to your patron Sam Smith Stevie Ray
Vaughan Texas flood from live at the el
mocambo official video Stevie Ray
Vaughan blues and I don't remember what
it was but when I first started learning
guitar Oh is a blues riff that was from
Stevie Ray Vaughan mm-hmm that's all I
remember
no Pecha don't remember what it was not
I remember it was Stevie Ray Vaughan
that my buddy was showing me yeah that's
a good place to learn from and also
didn't want to mention our patreon page
we do weekly q and A's and TV show
reactions but weekly John does music
video reactions because he is a musician
himself so yeah oh here to love for the
music
[Music]
[Music]
brothers so sweaty oh yeah I don't think
I've ever seen this dear avan nalla this
way
[Music]
healing
Jeff Daniels on bass
[Music]
finger-licking good
[Music]
summers
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
always it doesn't have to
[Music]
damn
[Music]
about to drop posted a racer
[Music]
[Music]
haha
my goodness
[Music]
it's got so many fingers hey the kids
just be eight of them doing this or plus
the folks
[Music]
[Music]
but man's back home the dams
[Music]
clutch on the beat
[Music]
gallopin face then guitarists make on
the track
[Music]
that should be a compilation video
asleep try not to guitar faces hey you
gotta close your eyes
yeah you got a feeling man but if you
read his eyes were wide open I was doing
that
this is making direct eye contact with
one guy so the weight directly
[Music]
damn look at that drip sweat
that's rock'n'roll juice okay I can keep
being this great when you're like cancer
all probably so sweaty I know I tunes in
the middle there's better this is off
okay everyone's noticing that's yeah so
wide if a guy who knows his instrument
[Music]
oh wait finish it hold it and [ __ ]
surprisingly not good at fingering girls
haha the number one complete of all of
his partners hey I thought he would have
been better
no rhythm in the sack oh yeah he spent
the last six minutes going I think I
would have turned behind my back I think
it was right
billion I think imma do hey let's get
some teeth in there what are all the
different impressive ways to play just
be able to be so in sync with your
guitar to this degree where
you don't even need it in front of you
yeah one like at that angle to be
playing in key still I can't even text
the proper message for that looking at
my phone directly
ah
[Music]
I'll play my guitar my bag isn't this
impressive just how sexy huh damn man
this band is NSYNC they're all that [ __ ]
new right there that's the thing is the
rhythm section has to be all over it
they gotta be so reliable that was great
yeah how about some some song with your
noodles straight down to the lyrics now
whatever he was yeah you know there was
a flood it was in Texas his baby he's
gonna get better flavors like Stevie Ray
Vaughn are doing that they're like half
improvising right like that's not
completely on oh no I'm sure that there
is a song like they still they're still
like freestyling up there typically in
in a shred as shreddy is this one and
especially for the Blues you know
especially for like barnburner blues
obviously he's got multiple scales at
work but yeah you just stay within the
proper scale you know what your licks
and noodles are and yeah you can kind of
just improvise from there I would
imagine and so much of this seems so
spontaneous like I'm sure a lot of these
licks probably figure in somewhere to
the recording versions but also since
this is live you know and especially era
that this was from there's a lot of
expansion you know because this song is
mostly a solo it's broken up by like a
couple moments of singing
I bet Stevie Ray Vaughan probably has an
IV ready to go backstage at any given
moment I bet he would have that guitar
strapped into his arm
that's why I put it behind his back he
needed a fix that that's like he's
sweating he's got a direct injection of
fluids coming into his system be good
he's gonna over swig is you're up there
it's hot you're in like a box and you're
also doing it's weird it's like guitar
players aren't necessarily the buffest P
I feel like drumming is the most overtly
physical activity but it is like when
you're cooking and not that I can speak
from
anywhere near this level of experience
but yeah you work him sweat man guitar
players like him make it look like
he's pressing buttons you know what I
mean yeah because a lot people actually
haven't like played guitar even try but
I remember when I was like a teenager
the first time I tried playing a guitar
I was so surprised by how hard you have
to put your fingers down you're not an
electric guitar you know ya like it
electric guitars are soft ground your
fingers so they're easier to press down
but it's not like just pressing a button
and he makes it look like he's just
pressing button yeah like damn how do
you do that so it's so incredible like
there's the strength and the fingers is
just so natural no I feel like I get
must be that it's like you've worked the
strength up to such a point that it
doesn't feel like it anymore cuz your
tolerance is so high because yeah I mean
this is like all these bends and poles
and stuff and he's jumping all over the
fretboard like it takes that level of a
finger strength and also you just you're
Sympatico with your instrument it's
tricky for me to jump around the neck
and stay and key and you know I mean
this guy is it seems like he's barely
even thinking about it you know I love
watching these kind of performances
because it's all about feeling I'd like
to just completely let go of the
logistics behind guitar playing or even
for the backup players the bass and then
not the backup players with the bass
player and the drummer rhythms and they
might not be doing anything that says
it's showy but they still have to be in
a feeling zone and just connect to they
got to hold the song together this was
so beautiful about it like when you're
watching what he's doing is like the
guitar is just an extension of his
emotions at that moment that's the
guitar face ya know it's like it's that
weird correlation where you're just like
I'm just expressing stuff my muscle
memory is so beautiful it would have
been really special to get to see him
play I feel like he was one of the ones
who left too early but man like I grew
up on on some of these performances and
it's been a long time since I've seen
Stevie Ryan like every time you watch
him play you're just like it's inspiring
but you're also like I could I don't
know how could you ever get to that
level yeah you just must play guitar all
free moments every day yeah getting on
that point ah love this thanks Sam
Spencer Center
this over dude this was incredible I've
only heard I've never seen him
performance Oh first time I've ever seen
his face he's a white guy I know yeah
surprise he's got that that griten is
voices playing the blues blues yeah yeah
black guy and they're playing you know
like yeah black music but by all
accounts and then you think Stevie Ray
Vaughan's contemporaries when the first
ones I got to is Jimi Hendrix can't say
it during the reaction that was like oh
[Laughter]
man
but yeah well thank you guys for being
here you make sure to subscribe to the
real rejects if this is on YouTube click
a notification about you know if I
woulda never got a video up Sam Smith I
know why he sent this over homeboy is a
guitar player that's his main passion in
life he wants to form his own band oh
yeah I asked him what his band should be
called flat out said Sam and the Smiths
yeah cuz you can't just call it the
Smiths yeah he said he would like to
form a band name whatever the players he
has he doesn't want to predetermine one
in advance okay and I said dude you're
never gonna have that happen you got to
just call the name right away do for
yourself just go solo as Sam Smith I
mean what could go wrong there look Sam
I'm just gonna give you some band name
ideas and now these are my band name
ideas so I don't want to ruin anything
for myself but if you have to take one I
totally get it first one was just
reel-to-reel rejects Oh
second one constipated diarrhea oh yeah
because I like the irony of it mm-hmm
and the third one was Greg Alba and the
fantabulous emancipation of one John
Humphrey that's our funk band yeah we do
just like 40-minute funk our disease my
emancipation is all over those keys and
we're always playing about you Sam Smith
thank you buddy appreciate it stay with
me